[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
15 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my very, very distinguished
colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good, Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very happy.
Very happy about actually
very nice weekend
that we spent at
LAUNCH Hackathon.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, we did.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And also very
excited about the content.
We're going to be talking
with Varun Tarwal-- sorry.
I did it for this time.
Nobody's here.
It's Varun Talwar, sorry.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Product
manager for gRPC.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Very exciting interview, and
gRPC is very interesting stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I've been using it
for a little bit
with other projects like
demos and Kubernetes,
and stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: Me too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very, very cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
after that, we're
going to also be talking
with Sara Robinson again.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we got a
really interesting question
of the week talking about
Firebase and mobile application
development.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And since we
don't know anything about it,
we decided that
Sara should be back.
So at the end of
the podcast, we'll
have Sara back to talk about
Firebase and mobile phones.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
But before we get
into those things,
I think we have a particularly
special cool thing of the week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It's a thing of
the week that it's
so cool that I almost
considered editing
the podcast from last week
to be able to talk about it.
But we decided not to.
But it's very exciting.
It's about Spotify, of course.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Oh, what's Spotify?
I've never heard of it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Spotify?
Yeah, it's this little thing.
They play music or something.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, something.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
They're a Swedish band?
I don't know.
No, they're really cool.
I've actually been using
Spotify for a very long time,
even before they started
working with Google.
And so I'm very excited
that they're finally
part of our customers.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So they
actually wrote a blog post.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, about
how they moved basically
their entire infrastructure
over to Google Cloud Platform,
so they could work-- what
is it, 75 million users?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And it's not only
the fact that they
moved Google Cloud Platform.
It's pretty cool.
But for me, the coolest
part is that not only it's
like they did a little
bit of shift and lift.
Like, whatever infrastructure
they were already using,
they moved it to the cloud.
But also they started using
a bunch of other Google Cloud
Platform managed services.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which
is pretty awesome.
And I have the list here.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
The ones I quite like-- like on
the big data side, especially.
We've talked with Felipe about
BigQuery, and stuff like that.
But they were using like
Hadoop, MapReduce, Hive,
a bunch of home grown stuff.
And they basically
came across and started
using all our stuff.
So Google Pub/Sub, Cloud
Dataflow, BigQuery,
Cloud Dataproc.
So they found, I
can only assume,
better solutions within
what we had for them
and will manage from trying
to manage their own stuff
on their own end.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And apparently
they were so happy
that some engineers
started tweeting about it.
And I have this tweet from-- I'm
going to call him Paul Lemaire,
because I think he's French.
And if he's not
French, hey, Paul,
this is an invitation for
you to come to the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
Tell us, literally, how
your name is pronounced.
We'd love to hear it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And you can also tell
us about your history,
how did it go using Google
Cloud platform and so on.
But there's actually
one specific tweet
where he tweeted, "Google's
BigQuery is the bomb.
I can start with
2.2 billion things
and compute summarize down to
20k in less than one minute."
MARK MANDEL: Which
is pretty impressive.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is,
indeed, pretty impressive.
So yeah, we'd love to have him.
So if by any chance you
are listening to it,
or if any of our listeners
knows personally Paul Lemaire--
MARK MANDEL: How many
degrees of separation
can we get from Paul Lemaire?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I'm sure that
someone that we know
might know someone
that knows him.
So let's make this happen.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So yeah, on top of
that, they're basically
using the whole cloud platform.
They're also using Cloud
Datastore and Cloud Bigtable.
And they're also using Cloud
VPN and Cloud Router and so on.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
it's a bunch of things.
I think it's a very cool--
it's a very cool thing that we
finally have someone as big
as Spotify, and so public,
because now I can go
and tell it to my mom
that-- she's definitely
not technical.
But she knows Spotify.
MARK MANDEL: So your mom
doesn't know Snapchat,
is pretty much
what you're saying.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think my--
MARK MANDEL: I
don't know Snapchat.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which is
probably better for you.
MARK MANDEL: It's better for
us, probably, [INAUDIBLE].
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Well, that sounds really cool.
So why don't we have
a chat with Varun.
I really want to
hear about gRPC.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Let's go with that.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
We are joined today by a
very special man, a man
by the name of Varun Talwar.
Varun is the product manager for
a lovely little project called
gRPC.
Varun, how are you doing today?
VARUN TALWAR: Good.
Thank you so much, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you
very much for having us.
We really like having you here.
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're
going to be talking about gRPC,
which is a great project.
I really love it, because
open source and everything
is out there, and
everybody can use it.
Everybody's using it, actually.
Lots of people are using it.
But before that, can you tell
us a little bit about yourself?
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah, sure.
Thank you, Francesc.
So my name is
Varun, as Mark said.
I'm a product manager
on a project called
gRPC, Google Remote
Procedure Call,
as some people like to fill it.
MARK MANDEL: Wait,
wait, wait, wait.
I heard that that was
not-- according to the FAQ,
gRPC stands for gRPC,
Remote Procedure
Call, which is amazing.
VARUN TALWAR: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
It's recursive.
VARUN TALWAR: It's a recurisve--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Recursive lag.
VARUN TALWAR: We like recursion.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
OK.
Sorry for interrupting.
VARUN TALWAR: So I have actually
recently taken on this role.
It is born out of
something called
Stubby, which Google has been
using for many, many years.
And it's awesome that we
have now open sourced it,
and the community can
use all the great things
that Google has built.
So I'm super excited
about the opportunities,
about taking gRPC
to enterprise companies,
to the community,
and to all the new use cases of
microservices, cloud, and IoT.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
OK, so we've seen that gRPC has
use cases-- like one of the use
cases is microservices.
So it makes it perfect
for-- nowadays,
like everybody is
using microservices.
But how could you describe
gRPC in like two sentences?
What is it exactly?
MARK MANDEL: You can use three.
It's OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
You're allowed.
MARK MANDEL: There's no limit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, you're allowed.
VARUN TALWAR: Well, yes.
If I had to say it
in like one line,
it would be, gRPC is a high
performance and efficient,
now open source
RPC framework, that
puts mobile and HTTP/2 first.
So it's really a general
purpose RPC framework
that anybody can use
to connect to systems,
and it supports a
whole ton of languages.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So let's maybe go
a little higher up.
Like we say RPC.
What does RPC stand for?
What is that, and why
do people use that?
VARUN TALWAR: Right.
So as many of you in this
audience I suppose would know,
RPC stands for Remote
Procedure Call.
I'll take you back to CS101 in
our undergrad schools, which
is, basically the way we
were taught, all of us
were taught RPCs was, you
know, you have a process,
but it's not running
on the same machine.
It's a remote process.
So how do you call it?
You basically--
RPC is a technology
where you define
what that service is.
You take all the arguments
from the calling machine,
you serialize,
you do marshaling,
send them over the wire.
There's an unmarshaling
happens, takes the arguments,
does the processing,
and sends back.
Right?
So that's how, conventionally,
we've all been taught RPC.
And that's what, at
the core of it, it is.
You know, request response.
But these days,
RPC frameworks have
become pretty sophisticated.
They can do synchronous,
asynchronous streaming
and all of those good things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So by the description you gave,
if I gave that description
to anyone, I'm sure that 99%
of people could say, oh, REST.
What is the difference with it?
VARUN TALWAR: Right.
So REST has pretty much become
a standard in how people
expose their sort of services.
You know, used to be the SOAPs
and WSDLs and sort of REST
really to con with the growth
of internet and sort of browsers
and mobile phones interacting
with internet services.
Primarily because,
you know, all it was
was sort of HTTP methods.
Right?
And they could flow through
proxies and firewalls,
and easy to call, easy to test.
So REST is great.
This is-- you know,
by no means gRPC is
saying that REST is not good.
REST continues to
dominate, and it's
great for a lot of use cases.
As a lot of you know, REST
is very resource oriented.
It stands for Representational
State Transfer.
You basically define the
resources on the server side,
and HTTP GET, PUT,
POST methods on top
of each of those resources.
Basically, cloud operations
on all your server
side resources is how REST
works, which is great.
What we have seen is
when people really,
really care about
performance, and they
care about what is being--
what format is being carried
on the wire, and trying
to squeeze out the best
performance, that is
where things like gRPC
shine, where we serialize
into binary over the wire,
as opposed to carrying JSON,
when we've seen, in some cases,
even crazy improvements like
100x, just by changing that.
The other thing is, for a data
center and cross data center--
large scale operations,
like the internet companies
of the world-- one,
performance is critical.
Second, there are
a lot of use cases
where it's not just request
response these days.
It's like with
push notifications,
and streaming data
sources, and streaming data
from all kinds of
connected devices,
people really want
bidirectional streaming--
both client to server,
and server to client.
And this is where,
again, gRPC is great.
Because it allows
you to establish one
TCP connection and send a ton
of messages on both sites,
with having efficiency
on the wire.
So I think these are
some of the use cases
where we are seeing
adoption of gRPC.
The other big
difference, I would say,
is-- in terms of
the mental model is,
if I were to put it in like
very, very simple terms-- REST
is very much nouns oriented, and
gRPC is kind of verbs oriented.
Right?
So the way you
define your services
is what your systems
and services can do.
And this is the service
definition language,
which is Google's
implementation is
based on proto, because protobuf
is what Google uses internally.
But gRPC as a
protocol is designed
so that you can use any IDL--
any Interface Definition
Language, in short, IDL--
and basically define
your services using any IDL.
And we are just the transport
which will carry our messages
efficiently.
Right?
MARK MANDEL: So
you mentioned IDL.
What does IDL stand for?
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah, so IDL is
Interface Definition Language.
The implementation
at Google for gRPC
uses protobuf, which is a
way you define your services.
So to take it a step further,
you define your methods
in proto.
We give you a compiler,
using which you--
which is called protoc.
You compile using that.
You get your client
and server side stubs,
and then you communicate.
At a high level,
that's what it is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That sounds a
little bit like Swagger, right?
VARUN TALWAR: Yes--
MARK MANDEL: Like the five
that you're describing,
methods and resources.
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah.
So yeah, Swagger is great.
So yes and no would
be the short answer.
So Swagger is--
MARK MANDEL: The easy answer.
VARUN TALWAR: Swagger
is great in terms
of its tooling around doc
gen, testing, sharing,
server specification and so on.
And it's greatly adopted
for rush services.
But we think of Swagger as a
great, complementary technology
that we want to actually
lean in and adopt
by having ways to convert
some of these serve IDL
files, protofiles, into Swagger.
And then, allowing people to use
all kinds of downstream Swagger
tool chains-- you know, tools
that they're familiar with,
so they don't have
to really change
the way they're using things,
in terms of doc generation,
testing, things like
API Explorer, and so on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So did that
mean that, at some point,
we might have some
protocol buffer definitions
and some tool to say, generate
the Swagger specification,
make a response to that,
and then use my swagger
explorer to do exactly-- like
to go over my protocol buffer
definitions.
VARUN TALWAR: You read my mind.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's awesome.
Is that actually coming?
Can you say a little bit?
Like is it something
that you are working on?
VARUN TALWAR: Yes.
It's actually being worked on.
I can go a step further and
say it's being used internally.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
VARUN TALWAR: So it's
not like just an idea.
It's actually--
MARK MANDEL: It kind of works.
VARUN TALWAR: It kind of works.
Yeah.
So coming soon is
what I can easily say.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's very good.
I'm very excited about that.
MARK MANDEL: That's awesome.
OK, so just to kind
of put a bow around it
a little bit, so
development flow with gRPC.
So we've got this IDL,
[INAUDIBLE] language.
So I write my protobuf file.
What does that
kind of look like?
What does that-- I know it's
kind of hard to say by voice.
But what-- sort of general
concepts, how does that look?
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah, so
proto-- and you know,
if you go to grpc.io, we
have great "Hello, World"
examples to actually
get you started on that.
But essentially, you say,
service any method name-- let's
say it's "Hello, World!"
You say a service.
"Hello, World!"
You say it's an RPC.
Input, you know-- let's say
I want to say, "Hello, Mark."
So I'll string name, and you
know, output string as well.
So that's all you're defining.
Then you say your message, which
is the actual payload that will
be used for the communication.
So you basically define
service and message.
You can think of it in sort
of a terms as your methods
and your data schema.
And you define those,
and we give you
a compiler to basically
compile and get
code generated in 10 languages.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
VARUN TALWAR: So, and you know,
I didn't say they're wrong.
It's actually 10 languages.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We're not going to ask
you to say it, all of those.
VARUN TALWAR: All of them.
Pretty much any language--
MARK MANDEL: I'm actually
wondering if I can remember off
the top of my head.
I want to see if
I get this right.
I know there's C,
C++, PHP, Java, Ruby--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Are you going to--
MARK MANDEL: Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, thank you.
I was like, really?
VARUN TALWAR:
Francesc [INAUDIBLE].
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Python, Objective C.
MARK MANDEL: Objective C.
VARUN TALWAR: Node.
MARK MANDEL: Node.
I know that's the
one we were missing.
There we go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
OK, so basically at the
end what we're doing
is-- what you write in the
protocol buffer definition is
basically like an interface,
a Java interface, or a Go
interface, really.
It's just the interface
with the method names
and the inputs and the outputs.
And then you're going to
auto generate the code
for the client and the servers.
And then the server is
going to be like, oh, you
have to actually define whatever
"Hello, World" actually does,
right?
VARUN TALWAR: Right.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
VARUN TALWAR: That sounds good.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds good.
All right, cool.
And then so once you've
generated that code,
it gives you a server that
you can run in that language.
And then you can start it.
And then you've got a client
that you can interact with,
as well.
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah.
So you call in
from client stubs,
and then you test and deploy it.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So we touched a little
bit on before-- you
said 100 times sort of thing.
I know performance depends.
But like latency
performance, have
you seen any sort of
benchmarks, or something
that you've seen that sort of
gives people at least somewhat
of a sense of how fast
this thing can really go?
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah.
So performance is a tough
one to answer because--
MARK MANDEL: It depends.
VARUN TALWAR: Depends is
the right answer, always.
It's a universally right answer
for performance questions.
But we have seen,
in all the-- I would
say three kinds of use cases.
One is service to services
in microservices world.
We have seen an
example from CodeOS,
who is using gRPC extensively
in the distributed k-values
to [INAUDIBLE].
Which is also, actually,
one of the underpinnings
in Kubernetes.
And they actually
put out a blog post--
I think it was the end of
last year, December of '15,
where they compared
it with JSON RPC.
And, you know, this is
simple put requests for etcd.
Which, for JSON RPC
was taking anything
in the order of about
250 to 300 milliseconds,
was then taking
about 6 milliseconds.
So you can--
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
It's nice.
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah.
And the [INAUDIBLE] pushes
out there in the public.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
like 40 times faster.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah, so--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's decent.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
VARUN TALWAR: The other
example I can give
is all-- a lot of
Google Cloud Services
are exposing a gRPC interface,
as well, in addition to REST.
Right?
Some, like BigTable,
are only gRPC.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which
makes sense if you really
care about the performance.
VARUN TALWAR: If you're somebody
like Bigtable and PubSearch,
like high performance throughput
and QPS sort of heavy systems,
then those are
the services which
are seeing huge advantages
from having a gRPC interface.
And the third one
I would say is--
which a lot of Google
services themselves,
including our core
mobile apps, are actually
in the process of
switching to a gRPC,
which, by the end
of the year or so,
I think we will have some
real numbers around what that
has been.
But we're super excited
with that journey
and the prospect of that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So I wanted to ask one
question, because I
keep on getting that
question over and over.
And if we don't ask it now,
it will be the question--
MARK MANDEL: It'l show up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
question of the week anyway.
MARK MANDEL: It'll show
up, yeah, in the bottom.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Which is-- OK, how
do you manage multiple
versions of an API?
That's something
that you have to do.
And of course one of
the options is like,
well, never do breaking changes.
Of course.
But in the real world,
you will have to do them.
How do you manage
that with gRPC?
VARUN TALWAR: Right.
So this is an area where proto
has actually shined and done
this well, within
Google, as well as
people who use
protobuf outside would
know that it sort of gives
you backward compatibility.
So for the-- if you've
written protobuf files,
you've seen that there's a
unique sequence number attached
with every field.
And the great
thing with protobuf
is that you can add new
fields to your message formats
without ever breaking
backwards compatibility.
So, you know, old
binaries are services
that don't know what those
fields are or what they mean.
Simply ignore it, right?
So thereby, you can basically
serve multiple versions
of your services to different
clients at the same time,
without a huge cost of change,
or without breaking changes
to existing clients.
MARK MANDEL: I see.
VARUN TALWAR: RIght?
So with proto, that's
a great thing, right?
And this happens all
the time at Google.
People update the
protos, push them in.
And the great thing is
all existing clients
continue to work.
Those who don't
understand or don't
know what to do with the
new fields just ignore them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
OK.
MARK MANDEL: So
you could do stuff
where like if you
added a field, and then
somebody sent in a message,
and you're like, oh,
that's missing, well then I'm
going to take this code down
this path.
But if it is there, then
I will do the new thing,
whatever that happens to be.
And you can kind of build in
your cases as you need to.
VARUN TALWAR: Right.
Right.
MARK MANDEL: That makes sense.
That makes a lot of sense.
OK, cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool So you also
mentioned that there
was-- we were actually
trying to make gRPC something
that is Mobile First.
And for Mobile First,
there's a couple
of things which is-- yeah,
performance is important,
but also data is
expensive and slow.
So could you talk a
little bit about that?
Like what's the difference
between gRPC and other things?
Like maybe just a blob, or
maybe JSON or maybe sheer XML.
It's got to be smaller
than XML, or JExpect.
MARK MANDEL: Or JSON
XML, which is a standard.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, really?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
VARUN TALWAR: I really don't
want to know what that is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so
could you discuss a little bit
about that?
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah.
So from the get go,
we wanted to have
gRPC be designed in a way
that puts mobile first.
So there are a few
answers, right?
Like one, which is
straightforward,
is basically both JSON and XML
sort of do Base64 encoding.
So instead of that with
binary over the wire,
that is where you get huge
efficiencies and advantages
from.
What does it mean
for mobile clients?
It means less data usage.
It means battery savings, which
are critical in today's times.
And especially if you're doing
things like real-time events
on your mobile apps, which
are both client to server
as well as a server
to client, this
is where, again, I think
bi-directional streaming
from gRPC helps a lot.
So in terms of
actual differences
with respect to JSON or XML,
or JSON XML, if that exists--
MARK MANDEL: [INAUDIBLE]
VARUN TALWAR:
Obviously, it depends,
in terms of actual
difference we get.
It depends on the use case.
But if you go look at our
documentation around protobuf,
just binary serialization I
think is-- it's 3 to 10 times
smaller than XML serialization
of structured data,
and anywhere from 20 to 100
times faster in terms of time
to process.
So remember, a
lot of these, it's
not just about the payload size.
It's also about
the time to parse,
which-- and you'll remember your
sort of good old days of SOAPs
and WSDL and XML parsing.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
VARUN TALWAR: Right?
So that is where a
lot of the development
cost-- not just CPU cycles
cost used to be spent.
So I think huge efficiencies
to sort of gain from that.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Seems like it would be a really
good fit for almost anywhere
that like-- we tend to think
in sort of web applications,
as well.
But anywhere that
needs low latency.
Like I'm thinking IoT.
We sort of touched on that.
VARUN TALWAR: Right.
MARK MANDEL: Obviously
mobile as well.
Gaming could potentially
be another option.
So there's a lot of places
that that could definitely fit.
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah.
I think for mobile.
So [INAUDIBLE], I
think we said it,
which is Objective C for
iOS and Android Java.
Both are something that
natively are supported for gRPC.
And we're seeing-- in fact, the
first kinds of use cases we're
seeing for mobile
apps are all around
either bidirectional streaming
or chat kind of use cases.
Or wherever payload
is heavily nested
in sort of a complicated
data structure
and nested-- deeply
nested payloads
is where you'll see
the biggest advantages
of binary serialization.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Very nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
So I actually have a
couple more questions.
MARK MANDEL: Go on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK,
so one of the questions
is-- it's actually a
double-edged question, which
is, OK, so why could
I do this instead
of just sending binary blobs,
binary encoding, right?
VARUN TALWAR: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
why don't I just like
whatever like in Java--
serialize and just send that?
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah.
And, you know, each
of the languages
have their own such framework.
Like Java has RMI library.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, the nightmares.
[LAUGHTER]
VARUN TALWAR: So there's a
whole lot of answers to that,
but primarily being
the ability to-- it's
not just serializing
on the wire,
but a standard way
to specify and share
services, a standard
way to upgrade and run
backward compatible services,
and a standard way where
not just how
services communicate,
but how services do interesting
things like health checking,
monitoring, tracing,
stats around them.
This is where one simplified
approach for Google
has given it a lot of benefits
and has allowed it to really do
a great amount of efficiency
around reliability, security,
operations
management, analytics,
which all become uniform.
And suddenly,
developers don't have
to think, well, how will I
talk to that system, right?
You don't have to think,
oh, which languages I've
written in?
I can tell you my personal
story, right out of college
writing a C backend which
talked to a Java-based front-end
and trying to hook JNI
libraries and always crashing.
MARK MANDEL: Ouch.
VARUN TALWAR: And being
very specific to how
two languages communicate.
So I think the-- if you
can take that worry out
and make sure it
works efficiently,
that's a huge, huge plus.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
VARUN TALWAR: And you
don't have to worry about,
oh, is the Java
out of my library
supports this kind
of serialization
and supports this structure,
but the one I'm talking to
actually does not.
So how do I--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And I'm assuming that
also versioning--
like we were talking about
versioning on binary blobs.
Just forget it.
VARUN TALWAR: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Not even try.
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So you've got
like this whole ecosystem
around things, and then you
can also sit back and be like,
OK, I'm going to use
the language that's
the right tool for
this job, and I
don't have to worry about
any communication at all.
VARUN TALWAR: Right.
And any new services
that keep coming up.
I have a new mobile app.
I write something
new for IoT devices.
They just don't have
to worry about how
I will talk to my
existing and new services.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
You had two questions.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I have?
Oh yeah, so my
other question was--
[LAUGHTER]
I was like why is he
looking at me now?
VARUN TALWAR: He was
floored by the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so there was-- yeah,
the other question
is still again
about something
really similar, which
is why-- if I'm using
protocol buffers,
I heard about this other
thing, FlatBuffers.
What is the difference?
Why I cannot use FlatBuffers?
Or can I use
FlatBuffers with gRPC?
VARUN TALWAR: You can.
So--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Actually, could you
explain also what FlatBuffers
is for our listeners?
VARUN TALWAR: So there are
various sort of variations
of protocol buffer out there.
One is, as Frencesc mentioned,
FlatBuffers, which is basically
trying to have--
at a concert level,
basically having data structure
represented the same way
in memory and in disk.
So you kind of
don't have to take
on this conversion serialization
and deserialization cost.
And, you know, something
there is picking up.
There is also another version
of protocol buffers called
nano protocol buffers, which is
more for IoT kind of scenarios,
making the payload even
smaller and even lighter.
So one great thing about
gRPC in terms of its design--
and, you know, kudos
to all the engineers
who started with
the design of it--
is it is designed to
be IDL agnostic, right?
So, in theory, you can swap
in an IDL of your choice.
Instead of proto, you can
use FlatBuffers, or NanoPB,
or Thrift, or other
IDLs, for that matter.
And it is-- you can swap it out.
There is some work on that.
But you could, in concept,
use it across IDLs.
And while I'm giving
kudos on design,
the other thing is,
it's not just IDL
agnostic, but transport
protocol agnostic.
So you could, in theory,
swap in HTTP/2 with QUIC
and get-- you know, do
smart things like that.
Which, for those of you
who don't know QUIC,
is an implementation
on top of UDP.
And some high media payload
use cases like YouTube
are really trying to
take advantage of those.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We had an episode
with Ilya Grigorik
and he discussed HTTP/2
and QUIC a little bit.
VARUN TALWAR: That was episode--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
VARUN TALWAR: I don't remember.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
For any listener that
is listening to this,
just find that Ilya
Grigorik episode
to-- if you want to learn
more about QUIC and HTTP/2.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, definitely.
Definitely.
Awesome.
All right.
I guess I have one
more question, which
is, what has been your favorite
project you've seen with gRPC?
VARUN TALWAR: Oh,
that's a good one.
MARK MANDEL: It's a
very good one, clearly.
VARUN TALWAR: Yeah.
So I'm trying to see
which is a favorite one.
So--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
not confidential.
VARUN TALWAR: And not
confidential, yes.
So I'll name one from
yesterday, which the code I got
is one of-- in
the top, up there.
Which was, a big client of GCP
was trying Pub/Sub over gRPC.
And this is something which is
pretty much ready, and ready
to be released.
And they were sort
of our early testers.
And they have--
basically they said,
OK, we will try something like
a million messages per second.
And simple, publish to
our topic and subscribe
sort of standard Pub/Sub.
And, you know,
they currently run
across huge number of
servers and data centers,
and they tested.
And basically the
developer who was testing
was just like, OK, let
me start on my laptop,
and then I'll move
on to data centers.
And he pretty much managed
to run out of one laptop.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, wow.
VARUN TALWAR: And his quote was,
I can serve half of my traffic
from my laptop, it seems.
I mean, of course it
was meant as a joke.
And in terms of
just-- he was just
trying to allude-- like
surprised by the amount of load
he could just serve
off a standard laptop.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
VARUN TALWAR: But I asked
him, can I quote you on that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Return to data
center, I have a laptop now.
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
Nice.
VARUN TALWAR: You know,
that just speaks to--
in certain use cases, you
just see humongous performance
improvements.
So that's one of my
recent up there ones.
Other than that, I think we are
very excited about what CoreOS
is doing with not
just etcd, but they're
using it across
in their new thing
called rkt, their new
thing called tectonic.
So it's widely being adopted
within their technology stack.
And yeah, we're excited to see
what, at Google and outside,
we can do with mobile use
cases and IoT, as well.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I think that we're
pretty much out of time.
MARK MANDEL: We are.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We are.
So is there anything
else that you
would like to mention before
we finish this interview?
VARUN TALWAR: We are--
first, go to grpc.io.
That's the first thing
you should do after--
MARK MANDEL: OK, excellent.
We will definitely have
that in the show notes.
VARUN TALWAR: There
is my call to action.
But yeah, I mean, we
are doing actually--
super excited to tell
our listeners that we
are doing our first
gRPC meetup tomorrow,
actually, it turns out.
MARK MANDEL: It'll actually
be yesterday, unfortunately,
by the time this comes out.
VARUN TALWAR: Oh.
MARK MANDEL: By the time-- yeah.
VARUN TALWAR: Let me be
specific on the date.
We are doing it on
3/1, 6:00 PM PDT.
Because we have a global
listener base, so yeah,
from the time we're
recording, 24 hours from now.
So excited about that.
I think we're actively looking
to talk to our community
members.
And if you're interested,
please join the mailing
list on grpc-io at
googlegroups.com.
It's on grpc.io.
Follow us on Twitter, @grpcio.
And, you know, we'd love to
talk more and not just get
your feedback, but hopefully
even get contributions.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well, thank
you so much for coming.
Thank you so much for helping
us understand a little bit
more what gRPC is and
what to use it for.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
VARUN TALWAR: Thank
you for your time.
Appreciate it.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you very much.
Thank you so much to Verun
for joining us today.
It was a pleasure and
delight to speak to you.
And, as a big fan of gRPC,
really exciting stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Very happy that he finally came.
And also looking forward
to the event tomorrow,
gRPC community event
down in Mountain View.
MARK MANDEL: It will
actually be yesterday.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
will be yesterday, indeed.
And I'm very happy
to see him there.
People from CoreOS,
people from Square,
Kelsey Hightower from our team.
So I think it's going
to be a very cool event.
MARK MANDEL: It's going to
be a really great event.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So before we finish
with this episode,
we're going to go through
the question of the week.
And as we mentioned
at the beginning,
today it's going to be
about how to use Firebase
on mobile applications.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And this question
actually comes from one of
the participants at launch
hackathon this last
weekend in San Francisco.
And he basically
came to our table
because he was considering
using Google Cloud Platform.
He was not very sure.
He came with a
bunch of questions.
And one of the
questions was, OK,
how do I handle authentication?
I want my users to use
password-- email and password.
And I was like, oh,
you should not do that.
The best way to manage
passwords is not managing them.
So Firebase, it
provides authentication
with a bunch of different
methods like Twitter,
and Facebook, and
stuff like that.
But it also provides
a very nice way
of doing email and password.
So he used that.
And then, after that, of course
he put everything on Firebase.
Because he was very happy
with it, super easy.
So yay.
And his question was like, OK,
so now I have a bunch of views.
And every single view needs to
access that data on Firebase.
What should I do?
Should I create one
reference and pass it around?
Or should I create a bunch of
references because whatever.
It's easy.
It's just easy.
Go ahead and do it.
And my answer to
him was, no idea.
So to answer that question,
we decided to just walk around
the building.
And we found two
awesome people that
decided to help us and just
come upstairs and talk to us.
So we're very happy to
have Sara Robinson back.
Hey, Sara.
SARA ROBINSON: It's
good to be back.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
Sara, who is a developer
advocate for Google Cloud
Platform in our team,
and also David East.
Hey, David.
DAVID EAST: Thanks
for having me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, thank
you for coming the whole four
floors, from the third
floor to the seventh floor
of the office.
DAVID EAST: I actually went
up three flights of stairs--
actually went up four
flights of stairs,
and then the door was locked.
So I had to go down
one flight of stairs,
and then walk across the
building to the elevator,
and then walk back across again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wow.
We can get you a
sandwich or something.
DAVID EAST: Yeah.
It was quite intensive.
SARA ROBINSON: We're
glad you made it.
MARK MANDEL: I'm glad you had
your exercise for the week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
David is a developer advocate
for the Firebase team.
And I think that you
had a pretty good answer
to this question.
Should I create references?
Should I pass them around?
What do I do?
DAVID EAST: Well,
a lot of people,
when they're first
new to Firebase,
they think, all right, when
I create this Firebase class,
initialize it, it's
kind of like a database.
So it's really
resource intensive.
So I want to keep
it around, and I
want to make sure
that I'm not just
creating these big objects
that consume all this memory
or suck up all this data.
And that's not really the case
with the Firebase reference.
Because when your app first
connects to your Firebase
database, that creates
a persistent web socket
from your app to the
Firebase servers.
And when you create
another reference,
it doesn't just go off and
create another WebSocket.
The Firebase SDK just shares
on that, the original socket
built. So there's only ever one
socket connected to the server.
So you don't have to worry
about like, oh, new reference,
new socket, new problems.
Like, no, it all
shares through the one.
So the Firebase SDK
handles that for you.
As far as creating
them, you can create
really as many as you want.
Like that's not going to be
the memory intensive part.
The memory intensive
part is actually
observing the real time
listeners for the data.
And that's really only as memory
intensive as how much data
you're trying to sync back.
Because that's-- bandwidth
is just bandwidth,
and slow internet connections
are slow internet connections.
So there's not too much
we can do about that.
But otherwise, you're totally
fine with just creating
a new reference inside
another view control,
or something like that,
and just synchronizing
that data to your views.
You shouldn't really be
using Firebase inside
of View, because
that messes up, you
know, the sacred NVC of iOS.
But still, you
don't have to worry
about just keeping one around.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so it's not like when
you think about
server applications,
where you have a database
connection with pooling,
and it's very resource intensive
and has all these connections.
It's much more
lightweight than that.
DAVID EAST: Yeah, exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So the
answer for this participant
could be, when you sign in,
you're going to get a UID.
And you create a reference.
Rather than creating
the reference
and then just passing
it around, just
pass the UID, which is
a simple [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID EAST: Actually, it
gets even easier than that.
You don't have actually
have to pass the UID around.
Because once you have an
authenticated user in Firebase,
you can actually-- for
iOS, you can say whatever.
You create a new reference.
The variable name is "ref."
So you say ref.authdata.
And as long as that user-- you
have a currently authenticated
user, that off data
property will be populated
with the current user.
So you can say ref.authdata.uid.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh.
DAVID EAST: So I
actually never have
to carry around any of
the user information,
because it's always available
on any reference you create.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
That's pretty awesome indeed.
DAVID EAST: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
There was actually
a second part of the
question, which was like, OK,
so I want to display
a list of things.
Here is a list of
skills, actually.
And he was like, oh, so I have
to go through all the JSON
that I'm getting,
the coding need,
and then adding it
to a different list
so it will appear somewhere.
And he was like, this
is kind of-- like yeah,
I know that I can do it,
but it's kind of annoying
that I have to write it.
Is there a better
way of doing this?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah.
There's actually a fairly new
library called Firebase UI that
helps you bind your Firebase
data to a table view in iOS,
or a list view in Android.
So it makes it really easy
to just listen for changes.
Whenever that data is
changed in Firebase,
add the new item
to the list view.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we'll add a link
to those to repose.
I'm assuming it's on GitHub?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah.
It's on GitHub.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
on the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, thank you very much
for coming and helping us
answer these questions today.
DAVID EAST: No problem.
Thanks for having us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So before we finish
this episode,
I wanted to talk about
the alternative cool thing
of the week.
We talked about Spotify,
which is a really cool thing.
I'm very excited about it.
But there's also a more
personal maybe cool thing
of the week, which is actually
that our podcast was launched
publicly on the Google
Cloud Platform Blog.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
we've got actually
a lot of new listeners.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
So if you're new to
the podcast, welcome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Welcome.
And it's amazing,
because we actually
created this podcast thinking
about, you know-- it was like,
maybe someone will be interested
on listening to this podcast,
who knows?
But we're actually getting
listeners from everywhere
in the world, which
is pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Which is awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I wanted to mention
something specific, which
is the second biggest country
for our listeners is Japan.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which
is pretty amazing.
So yeah, if you're
Japanese, hey.
I'm very happy that you're
actually enjoying our podcast.
I really like this.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
send us your questions.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, definitely.
In English, please, though.
Actually, if you send
them to us as Japanese,
we do have some
Japanese speakers
who could translate them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: In
our team, there's
actually four people
that speak Japanese.
MARK MANDEL: It's
true, there is.
There's four.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Which is pretty crazy.
And only one of
them is Japanese.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
that's pretty amazing.
Cool.
So before we
finish, where are we
going to find you,
Mark, next week?
MARK MANDEL: So
I'm not going to be
anywhere special in the next
couple of weeks, unfortunately.
But I did just get
accepted for Dev Objective.
It's a web development
conference in Minneapolis,
which is in-- where are we?
14th of June.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: So
that'll be good fun.
I'll be there talking
probably about something
about communities, I expect.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Something
about communities!
Who knows?
Cool.
I'm going to be in San Francisco
next week for most of the week,
and then I'm going to
be on my way to Austin.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: For
South by Southwest.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're going
to have a bunch of parties.
That's going to be
so much fun though.
MARK MANDEL: You're
going to have a blast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We're going to have Cloud Spin.
We're going to have a
bunch of talks, and events,
and the Cloud Vision
API robot, and a bunch
of really cool things.
We have a Fiber Space
there in Austin.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
yeah, really great space.
So if you're going to be
anywhere in Austin next week
for South by
Southwest, come say hi.
We're going to be at the
Fiber Space most of the time.
And we're going to have cool
swag, cool demos, and probably
drinks at some point.
So come say hi.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
before we finish,
I wanted to-- since we
didn't do it last episode.
MARK MANDEL: And we have
all these new listeners.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And we have
I think we should do this.
Which is, how do
people contact us?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
If you want to send us
questions of the week, things
that are cool, we
definitely want to hear it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So people
can send us e-mails at--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: E-mails.
You got me there--
hello@gcppodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
Twitter.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: @gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Reddit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's the
subreddit r/gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Google Plus?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: +gcppodcast.
Or you can also search Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
And on the web?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: On the
web, gcppodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: Pretty easy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
So thank you so much
for this great episode.
I had so much fun today.
MARK MANDEL: Me too.
I'll see you next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]